joe ross to the hill two and one with a
4.64 era fps last time out got the win
allowed just one run in six innings yeah
just five hits two 91 pitches four
strikeouts one walk he's allowed one run
or less in three of his last four starts
so after a rainy day in washington the
braves are ready to go and acuna first
pitch line drive hit to left field it's
down for a base here one pitch one hit
and the braves are in business to start
the game and here's the nat's killer
freddie freeman batting just 216 this
season does have those seven homers and
18 driven in
and there's a great slider down and into
freddy freeman
swings through it for the first out big
one anytime you get that guy out here's
ozuna let's see if they try to make him
go the other way tapper back to joe ross
to second for one and a scoop by josh
bell
a one four three double play gets joe
ross out of the first inning
had great success up there on april 7th
went five innings in the first game of
the twin bill up in
washington and
look outside that one start in chicago
he's been spot on in pretty much every
other start hitting spot striking guys
out hopefully we see that tonight turner
at 309
is riding a hot streak for the nationals
turner pops this one into right and it's
down in front of acuna there goes the no
hitter trey turner taking care of that
right away going the other way that's
when he's at his best the leg kick
a little lean you to right and now the
fun starts so a new pearl for inoa and
the pitch is on the ground right into
the shift dansby the turn and both
starters get inning ending double plays
in the opening frame we're off and
running in washington no score braves
and that's game one
william contreras 23 years of age out of
venezuela
taps this one back to joe
and a little flip
gives the nationals
an easy second inning still scoreless in
dc
2-2
is tapped back to the mound weak contact
you know uh breezes through the second
inning off we go to the third christian
pache will lead off in washington
christian pache leads off on one pitch
is in the air
shallow right center harrison ranges up
drops the ball
in and out of the lever of josh harrison
and the braves get a break
ponte is aboard to start the inning
break for the brave see if they can take
advantage so tough assignment now for
joe ross runner at second with one away
and
ronald acuna in who singled
firmly to left field back in the first
this one struck well to center field
robles back
and a nice lunging
catch dives onto the warning track
corrals it what a play that ball is
absolutely roasted another hard hit ball
for rob the county junior standing over
from the crowd here at nats park and
roblox fully extended diving into the
wall what a play by victor robles juan
soto proves
fly ball
shallow left center
robles camps under it and joe ross is
out of a jam in the third robles the
hitter you know in an inning you start
mixing in those locks you just give them
so much more time as you see roblox
strikes out on that
breaking pitch you see how sharp that
one was that was in the left-hand
batter's box
no chance for robles who tried to check
his swing twice and got rung up
the swastika six starts partner one
start was no walks four starts with one
walk and only one start with two walks
so that's outstanding you'll take that
without question another comebacker he's
had a handful of those and freddie
freeman cleans it up at first you know
has faced the minimum through three
scoreless innings
here's austin reilly
ground ball up the middle
right to the shift harrison to the bag
and across
for the 4-3 double play
two double plays turned by the nets
behind joe ross so far tonight
that is ripped into the left field
corner that's a bummer
because that would have scored a run
gansby will stop at second that's a two
out hit for the brave shortstop
that's his fifth double of the year
popped out to right center field robles
and hernandez victor robles will take
charge six rbis in the last three games
for bell
strike three down away strike bell
didn't like it but he is wrung up that
was a perfect pitch lost
issues a walk and nothing else as we
head to the fifth
strike three call second strikeout for
joe ross who else it's ronald acuna
junior
and a fly ball hit toward that
scoreboard in right center did he get
enough of it yes he did ronald lacuna jr
breaks a scoreless tie with a two-out
solo homer he's in double digits 10th
homer of the year in the braves strike
first it's one to nothing
leave it to him to get the braves on the
board yeah i think he's able to subtract
and add some speed to that
on the ground dansby 360 spin and a
perfect throw to take care of
mr castro that was slick good play by
dansby and to her out look at where
contreras sets up good target
and right down broadway he took another
curve ball yeah well thank you very much
it was a mistake but the pitch was so
bad it was good and the braves preserve
a one-nothing lead the braves rookie
catcher william contreras again the
pitch and he went down and got it
engulfed it into left center field for a
base hit that'll score albies
contreras with his second rbi
extends the atlanta lead and what a
piece of hitting jeff to go down and hit
a seven iron into left center field so
atlanta has them loaded with two outs
lost scary noah's coming up
and a high fly ball center that ball is
going to go it's a grand slam for noah
[Applause]
that was a no doubter he knew it too
look at the smile on you noah's face so
andrew stevenson's going to pinch it
swaying enemies there's that
disappearing slider and contreras with a
laser to first
and that is strikeout number four 440
noah who is feeling it tonight and the
phillies come to play here at troost
park that one is smoke dansby nice play
backhanded shovel step on the bag throw
to first it's a double play
another 2-2
tapped back over noah that'll play josh
bell
swanson makes the play for the second
out but the nationals are on the board
here in the seventh
this feels good seeing him in the
batter's box doesn't it
i don't care what the score is
missed the last eight games with that
left shoulder strain
swinging a miss
97 from tyler matzick
and we're in out away from a series
opening win and minter ready with his
2-2
he got him to swing and miss and that is
your ball game
well pitched well defended and big time
home runs from ronald lacuna junior and
waskar inoa who wins his third game